[Music]
what happens to us after we die the only
way to find out is to see for ourselves
now tell me about medical training for
this movie because I heard you guys went
through a little bit of a bootcamp yeah
we did we learned all the terminology
what words we were filling out and how
to resuscitate each other there's a
couple things that I learned like the
movie magic of it you know like the CPR
because otherwise it would break each
other's script yeah some of it a little
real another thing I would not trust
myself to actually perform them thank
you I want to ask you about a future
project coming up because I believe you
are my iris West
I am your Harris the Barry Allen in that
we've met Ezra Miller's is very
different from Grant Gustin so how is
your iris West different from the one we
met on the show I think always I mean to
be honest I haven't tried her at all
because I want my iris West to be his
own world which it really is the TV
series you know from the movie but we
don't even know what time we're gonna
like in what time because it's going
back and forth past and future with the
class we don't even know what time we
were you actually me iris so we'll see
and we're doing flashpoint so yeah it's
gonna get all kinds of crazy oh I think
it's gonna get really wicked but it's
gonna be so fun I'm down for whatever
where are you guys on that process right
now we're in the process of still
replacing our director and we just got a
new script obviously flash boy so me and
Ezra I guess it was hanging out
[Music]
you